i have a crazy story with bam actually
let's hear it
so i'm from redlands california and um
one day i'm just sitting at my house and
i get a
text message because uh i guess bam's
photographer is a mutual friend of mine
or something
ryan g uh
some
illegals illegal vehicle some i don't
know what it was but uh
he texted me he said yo bam once and uh
once the job i gave him and i was like
yeah of course bam and he hits me up and
he's like yo um because i'm from
redlands california he's like i'm doing
something at redlands skatepark for like
their grand opening or something oh this
was for like he made a music video or
something no no no this is something
else that was the when the dude fell
through the [ __ ] thing yeah that was
funny um so
he was like i'm gonna hit him up because
i know he zan's from redlands you know
so i was like [ __ ] yeah i'm stoked so we
sent a
a chauffeur to come get me and my
friends but he had a request he said can
you bring a gun because i've never shot
a gun before
and i was like bama or jerry asked me
for a gun
i gotta get a gun like let's go get a
gun let's make this epic you know let's
go to the back wash because there's like
you know washes back there where
nobody's going to hear it and stuff so
are you a gun guy have you yeah yeah i i
i i like going to ranges and stuff and
it was a legal gun obvious obviously it
was illegal but um serial numbers were
scratched yeah yeah
bullet yeah
hollow hollow uh points no but uh so we
went we ended up going
and um
uh he did like a little interview with
me it was kind of awkward i didn't know
it was really going on this wasn't
terribly long ago right like yeah this
was this was about a yeah exactly a year
ago you know
at that time uh or maybe yeah maybe clip
made like a year and a half yeah yeah it
could yeah it could have been like
longer um
and uh so we did the skatepark thing you
know it was uh they're having an event
and people were kind of taking pictures
of him me it was cool and then danny
wade was there too danny wade was one
that brought him and i'm a big you know
i uh i i grew up skateboarding i was
never good but i i still enjoyed the
culture and danny way jumped the great
wall of china like for sure so you know
and that's who took bam the redlands so
i showed up we all met i got to meet uh
danny way legend got to meet bam you
know legend too it was sick um
and then we had the guns like well let's
go shoot the gun i'm like jesus i'm
really about i'm in my hometown with
bamar jaren danny [ __ ] way
and i brought them a gun
and robotically shoot it off
and
in the fields like far away from
anywhere where it would be bad but bam
was telling me he had never shot a gun
before and that's why he wanted to do it
and i was like damn how in the [ __ ] is
there any way you've never shot a gun
before you crazy ass [ __ ] you
know what i mean but i guess he hadn't
because he was shaking when he held that
gun
uh i'll show you videos after this too i
have it
um and yeah we went to the the little
backwash and and shot guns uh for a
little while danny way went crazy on it
what kind of gun was it oh it was just a
glock nine millimeter
um and yeah and after that uh we just
parted ways and that was my bam
experience cool didn't he like shoot the
car or something
uh we were shooting at like bottles in
the back because uh we didn't want to
shoot up rocks and ricochet and die why
did you post did he post on a story one
time he got
this was also right after his bentley
was stolen and crashed
yeah so he was telling me about that
stuff too
yeah yeah it's a pretty gnarly situation
man yeah i i'm i'm slightly familiar
with it um but i'm not you know
obviously too familiar with the whole
situation yeah i see him working out on
like novak's instagram right and yeah he
told me a lot of crazy stories about
novak too but um
like like i'm not trying to like talk
[ __ ] on bam because like all of you guys
are legends you know jackass is amazing
you know jeff germain and spike jones
all you know amazing people but um he
just didn't seem like himself he kind of
just well right i mean at that time he
wasn't himself
there's nothing about uh he was still
getting a lot of love from everybody
he's a likable guy i mean people like
him they always will yeah anything
negative like and this kid is amazing
yeah yeah yeah you're not talking [ __ ]
to say that that's yeah and everybody
wants bam to be
in the best place and yeah happy and
healthy and
yeah america if you thought jackass
forever was crazy oh boy do i have a
show for you it's a multimedia comedy
show called the bucket list tour and the
stuff i filmed for this show is way too
hot for jackass like the general
anesthesia bike ride the vasectomy
olympics and sky jacking the footage is
so intense we have full grown men
passing out at almost every city this
bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]